well the new matrix is out and it got me
feeling like nigel a runner null pointer
runner stevens agent
simon arena
freeman 713 i'm a sentinel
it's been over 18 years since the
original matrix trilogy came to an end
and resurrections had to come along and
make me even more confused
so if you were like me and found
yourself scratching your head begging to
be blue pilled because you didn't
understand what was going on this is the
video for you we'll be going over some
of the biggest unanswered questions
timeline details and little things you
missed along the way
so grab a red pill and follow me down
this rabbit hole as we explain matrix
resurrections time to fly like the
original matrix resurrections begins
with a blinking green prompt we know the
story this is how it all began we're
watching the beginning of the original
matrix through the eyes of a new
character called bugs but something is
off trinity is played by a different
actress morpheus is agent smith and
things just aren't happening the way
like we saw in the original this is
because we're witnessing events in a sub
program called a modal think of it like
the movie inception you have the real
world a dream world and a dream within a
dream world only in this version you
have the real world the matrix and the
modal within the matrix this modal was
created by thomas anderson aka neo it's
actually his code for a video game
called the matrix which is one him and
his business partner smith many
accolades but what neo doesn't know is
that he's stuck in a new version of the
matrix but to understand how we got here
we need to figure out what happened
between the end of matrix revolutions
and the beginning of matrix
resurrections revolutions ended with neo
sacrificing himself to save humanity
essentially brokering a piece between
man and machine just how long do you
think this piece is going to last
remember that neo contains the source
code to the matrix if there's no matrix
the machines can't harvest the power
from their endless fields of human
batteries neo sacrificed himself
allowing his source code to be extracted
and the matrix reinstalled in exchange
for peace between man and machine this
is why we see the sentinel standing down
at the battle of zion and the oracle
back in the matrix as a new dawn arrives
in the background later in the film when
neil reunites with niobe who you may
remember from reloaded and revolutions
she tells him that an energy scarcity
started a civil war between the machines
in this shot here we can see how even
the machines are colored red and blue
like the pills this color contrast is
used all throughout the film although
niobe doesn't go into great detail here
it's my interpretation that this battle
was between the architect one of the
creators of the original matrix and the
analyst an ai promising an improved
version eventually the analyst prevailed
as he proved his version of the matrix
could control humans better while
simultaneously extracting more power but
how did he do this how did he make such
an enhanced version of the matrix the
key the bond shared between neo and
trinity the key to it all
you
and her
quietly yearning for what you don't have
while dreading losing what you do as the
analyst states the older version of the
matrix mystic key element a human
element feelings the two most important
of which are desire and fear at the end
of reloaded we meet the architect who
had an absolute disdain for humanity
whereas he pushed aside humanity in his
coding the analysts embraced it
incorporating it into his version of the
matrix manipulating humanity's desires
and fears to maximize energy output the
worse we treat you the more we
manipulate you
the more energy you produce
after the deaths of neo and trinity he
pieced together their bodies and
extracted the source code to create his
own improved version of the matrix and
when the suits those ai the analyst
reports to found out about how much more
efficient this matrix was the switch was
made but what the analysts and machines
don't realize is that this version of
the matrix contains a bug literally a
character named bugs she was a normal
blue build window washer living her life
in the matrix when she saw a version of
neo jump off a building it's not clear
how many times bugs witnessed this
before she bugged out because we know
the matrix loops we can't see it but
we're all trapped inside these strange
repeating loops the architect's matrix
had already gone through five iterations
before we got to the version of neo we
see in the trilogy what makes things
more confusing is that the analyst has
given neo something called a dsi or
digital self-image so while we see him
looking like keanu reeves within the
matrix he looks like this guy in the
mirror so anyone trying to find him
would have a hell of a hard time hence
why it took nearly 20 years to reach him
to make things even more confusing 60
years have passed in the real world
hence why we see naobi looking much
older so we have this character bugs who
knows neo the one is alive and she
believes she can find him something
inside her compels her to search the
modal something is happening here
something important that's because the
creator of the modal thomas anderson
subconsciously left a back door to
access it knowing that someone like bugs
will come in and eventually free
morpheus thomas anderson was smart and
hid morpheus in the agent smith
character and only when the two meet as
he snap out of his loop take the red
pill and join bugs on her quest i am
morpheus
and i have to find neo within the matrix
the analyst masquerades as neo's
therapist this allows him to keep tabs
on how neo's feeling gaslight him and
prescribe him medication that will keep
him complacent even thomas anderson's
design role in the matrix that of a
video game developer is merely a veneer
to hide the fact that his visions of the
past weren't real but rather figments of
the game he was developing at deus
machina the video game company thomas
anderson works at a name that literally
means god machine from latin we learn
that agent smith is his business partner
he too goes about his life not knowing
who he really is it's only when thomas
anderson awakens to the realization that
he is neo that smith realizes he is
agent smith i feel bad about this tom
after all you are the one who set me
free that's because there's an
inseparable link between these two
characters he used our bond
and turned it into a chain in matrix
revolutions the oracle tells neo that he
and agent smith were created to bring
balance one being the ying to the
other's yang he is you
you're opposite you're negative
the result of the equation trying to
balance itself out with neo successfully
red pilled and brought back to the real
world were introduced to the new city of
io led by naiobi io's an interesting
name with a double meaning in tech speak
it's short for input output but it's
also the name of a mortal lover of the
greek god zeus another interesting fact
is that bug's ship the nemesin is named
after the greek god of memory when neo
awakens in the resurrection pod he sees
trinity across from him the analysts
purposely put their pods close together
as it helps stabilize and maximize the
energy output it's here that the main
story of resurrections begins neo has to
save trinity from the matrix so when neo
goes back into the matrix he's pursued
by agent smith now agent smith wants one
thing for neo to stay out and let him
deal with the analyst all you have to do
is stay out of the matrix and leave the
good doctor to me he believes that neo
isn't ready to take on the analyst and
by doing so he'd jeopardize smith's
newfound freedom i won't have his leash
on my neck again he's even amassed a
group of exiles a batch of programs that
rather than face deletion have hidden
themselves from various iterations of
the matrix this includes the merovingian
who has gone from upscale french [ __ ]
to hobo french [ __ ] he's not really
important to the story at all i guess
they just wanted to put him here as
fanservice meanwhile an urgent message
from sati is delivered to neo and niobe
satya you might recall was the young
girl from matrix revolutions whose
father helped her escape deletion turns
out he also designed these special
resurrection pods for trinity and neo so
she has some inside info on how neo can
rescue trinity and this rescue has to
happen soon since the neo's escape has
caused the matrix to destabilize which
has caused a fail-safe to revert back to
a previous version of the matrix but the
only thing preventing that from
happening is the analyst who has put a
temporary stop to it he's convinced the
suits that he can get neo back so
basically neo has to choose between
going back in the pod forever to
maintain stability in the matrix or risk
both his and trinity's life and
destroying everything in the process the
plan is pretty complicated they can't
just unplug and steal trinity's body
from the resurrection pod if they did
that the analysts would know and
immediately have her killed so they
designed this crazy scheme to have bugs
take over trinity's matrix body for just
a brief moment while they transfer
trinity's pod connection to this flying
machine called kujaku i hope everyone's
following kujaku acts as both an uplink
to the matrix as well as a vehicle that
transports trinity back to the ship you
can see this brief transfer depicted in
the movie when it looks like trendy's
body is split but before we get there we
learn that trinity has to make the
choice of leaving the matrix on her own
just like neo did if she doesn't make
that decision on her own it could kill
her extracting a confused or an
uncertain mind will
in all probability kill her but it's
kind of a moot point since the matrix
has always toyed with the idea that we
don't have a choice everything is
predetermined the choice is an illusion
you already know what you have to do at
the last minute when it looks like
trinity or tiffany as she's called in
this version of the matrix is going to
stay she changes her mind this causes a
showdown between them and the analyst
whose time freezing ability which neo
was unable to counter is foiled by agent
smith the analyst isn't sure how smith
isn't affected by this his program has
seemingly gone row free from his
constraints which is only explained by
this one line once he got out let's just
say i was free to be me so it's pretty
vague what actually happened here he
ends up shooting the analyst giving neo
and trinity enough time to escape ending
their quote-unquote alliance what ensues
is a massive swarm chase sequence where
bodies controlled by the analysts
literally plunged to their deaths to
stop neo and trinity as they make their
escape it all culminates in a literal
leap of faith off the top of a building
as a new dawn rises but what happens
here is really unexpected trinity flies
saving neo from his death she seems to
have the powers he did in the original
trilogy my best interpretation of this
is that because this is a new matrix
that is inextricably connected between
neo and trinity the two share these
powers that's why you'll see the two of
them flying at the very end it's
probably just for dramatic effect that
we have her unlocking her powers to save
him at this very moment just like he
saved her in the trilogy remember he
literally took a bullet out of her the
two of them confront the analyst and
learn the suits try to activate the
failsafe but couldn't without the source
code regardless the analyst actually
thinks they're gonna go back to their
pods on their own and let him control
the matrix because at the end of the day
people like to be controlled and they
like the world he made and trinity and
neo are like hell no and decide to make
some changes on their own so it looks
like resurrections ends with neo and
trinity ruling the matrix together being
able to change whatever they want i also
imagine this would allow them to have
leverage in the real world against the
machines if they control the matrix they
also control the flow of energy so there
you have it matrix resurrections what
did you think of the new film and where
would you rank it i want to hear your
thoughts and theories below thanks for
watching everyone make sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you